when you think of Meg Ryan it's likely
that her widely successful romantic
comedies come to mind with roles in
films like When Harry Met Sally
Sleepless in Seattle and you've got mail
however in 2003 Ryan starred in a film
unlike anything she'd done before
completely polarizing her fans in the
process in Jane campion's erotic
Thriller in the cut Ryan received such
an adverse reaction to performing a
graphic nude scene that it ended up
being an unexpected turning point in the
actor's career despite some backlash
from viewers Ryan told the New York
Times she had a great time filming the
movie Ryan stepped out of the Limelight
for a few years before returning for a
series of independent films following
them up with a directorial debut in
2015 however she told the New York Times
that her separation from Hollywood was
Mutual she now spends her time traveling
writing designing and taking pictures